[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui serge
regourd son livre elle souhaite
sculpture le désintérêt pour la culture
de la part des politiques ne date pas
pour lui de l'épidémie de kevin 19 il
est bien antérieur il va nous en
expliquer les origines et les
conséquences je reçois également terrain
saillard at la chanteuse du groupe pop
la vague qui sort en solo chinoise une
chanson sur le racisme anti asiatique on
va voir le clip qui vient juste de
sortir et la violoniste l'ia petrova qui
sera un album de concerto pour violon
composées par mozart et beethoven mais
l'on commence tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle voici votre
réponse à tous les trois en images on
commence par là votre ligne à petrova
c'est la pyramide du louvre pourquoi ça
ici exactement se déclare ravi de le
mans en fait je suis je me suis promené
il ya quelques semaines et je suis passé
à côté j'ai vraiment choqué par ce que
j'ai pu parce que on voit jamais le
louvre vide comme ça on avait
l'impression que le musée d'or que le
culture d'or et samassa m'a choqué mais
en même temps je trouvais que c'est bon
parce que d'un côté vous voyez c'est
totalement sombre et ça nous rappelait
un tout petit peu aujourd'hui je trouve
autres comme moi c'est l'autre
et de l'autre côté on voit clairement de
lumière et on se dit que quand même il
ya de l'espoir il ya enfin j'espère et
du coup j'ai mais j'aimais bien ce
contraste entre entre côté sombre et
locaux qu'elles diminuent eh bien on en
parlera avec serge regourd effectivement
ce ce désintérêt pour la culture mais on
regarde d'abord l'image de l'image de
thérèse alors là il faut que vous nous
expliquiez thérèse alors c'est une photo
que j'ai prise l'été dernier à arles et
il s'avère qu'en fait il s'agit d'une
ancienne librairie dont certaines
lettres ont disparu à part visiblement
ou invisiblement est en fait ne reste
que les qui lie les lettres elle
m et pour moi cette photo c'est une
invitation à lire entre les lettres et
voilà est en fait je trouvais que cette
photo de devanture un peu délabré
représentait pas mal l'époque et quelque
part je me dis que c'est une librairie
qui est fermée avec des fenêtres des
grillages etc et on est dans une époque
où effectivement les réseaux sociaux
prennent le pas sur la lecture ou je te
faut qu'on dit plus assez de livres et
or la liberté se sont peut-être à
travers à traverser aussi
et du coup voilà pour moi la liberté
c'est quelque chose qui choque qui se
cherche et qui se trouve et il ya la
fenêtre du dessus qui elle est
entrouverte
le soleil tape sur le mur est en fait je
me dis qu'il ya peut-être une lueur et
le cam d'espoir voilà à tout cet atout
de cette comment dire à tout ce chaos
ambiant et du coup moi j'essaie de
passer par cette fenêtre
serge regourd
alors évidemment c'est très différent
c'est très différent des deux images
précédentes mais sa licence de rendre
compte le sable est il de l'air du temps
un dominant il ya deux éléments d'une
part le masque auquel nous sommes tous
contraints depuis déjà un certain temps
et ce qui est aujourd'hui l'information
en quelque sorte main stream qui est qui
et surtout les médias qui est la
question du séparatisme de l'islam de la
laïcité et il me semble que sont les
deux sujets dominants qui sont traités
par les médias de masse ces derniers
temps il doit imams qui m'est apparu que
cette image constitue en quelque sorte
un concentré des deux est évidemment
l'alliance des deux n'exprime pas de
prime abord principe de liberté
n'exprime pas un principe de société
parfaitement assumé on a parlé un
instant du chaos
et là c'est une forme de chaos c'est la
fermeture est me semble-t-il de surcroît
c'est une synthèse de des confusions
ambiante
c'est à dire que ici et là sur les
réseaux sociaux dont on en parlait ce
type d'image est assortie de
commentaires selon lequel en quelque
sorte il y aurait une contradiction à
interdire la burqa et à imposer le
masque sanitaire comme si ces deux
questions relever du même registre et je
pense évidemment des deux questions sont
totalement différentes et que faire une
analyse commentaires politiques
soulignant une contradiction crois même
que le washington post a raillé en
quelque sorte la france d'imposer le
masque au moment même où on voulait
interdire la burqa or pour moi c'est
évidemment une forme de confusion qui
d'une certaine manière
[Musique]
et tenez co raccourci à beaucoup de
confusion qui me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui domine dans un certain
nombre de représentations sociétale et
bien commençons
[Musique]
et commençons par vous serge regourd
vous êtes juriste départ professeur
d'université vous êtes l'auteur de très
nombreux articles et livres sur la
culture dont un que sais-je sur
l'exception culturelle
aujourd'hui vous publiez sos culture
chez indigène éditions vous y accusait
les politiques d'avoir abandonné toute
politique culturelle digne de ce nom
et cela bien avant l'épidémie de kovy d'
au fond vous dites un peu la même chose
en ce qui concerne les politiques que
qu'on dit pierre nora et et marcel
gaucher en fermant leur revue le débat
il ya peu de temps et qui disait au fond
le long n'est plus haut niveau il ya
plus le niveau n'est plus là les
politiques ne sont plus haut niveau les
médias non plus ne sont plus haut niveau
oui d'ailleurs je mentionne sur tille au
mans le bouquin est un format court
cette parenthèse pour indiquer que le
projet a été celui des des éditeurs qui
ont à l'époque publié le fameux indignez
vous de stéphane hessel et qui m'avait
proposé un petit bouquin sur la culture
avant même le début de la pandémie et
j'avais choisi le thème le titre est
soit la sculpture parce qu'avant même la
pandémie il m'était apparu au fil de
précisément de plusieurs expériences
notamment de deux les enseignements et
de mes recherches à l'université que ont
géré le quotidien certes sur la base de
l'acquis extraordinaire puisque pour
aller vite
l'état français déjà sous l'ancien
régime s'est construit d'une manière
consubstantielle à la question
culturelle c'est à dire que la la
culture a été un élément de conception
et d'édification de l'état national et
il m'était apparu que déjà depuis
plusieurs décennies en gérer le
quotidien mais qui avait plus du tout de
l'ambition culturelle qui a plus de
finalité est que ne savaient plus quelle
était véritablement les objective les
finalités qui pouvait légitimer une
politique culturelle et dont je le
signale la fin à l'effet de la parution
du débat qui était
un élément du débat public
un support du débat public est en effet
cette loi qui voulait de rappeler et
nora ont considéré que ça n'avait plus
de sens aujourd'hui dans la mesure où la
plupart des intellectuels accepter le
monde de tel qu'il est alors je
l'apostropha quelque sorte courtoisement
respect relais politiques mais pas
seulement les politiques également les
artistes parce que il ne sommes que dans
ce type de domaine il n'ya pas
d'unilatérale itd d'exclusivité des
responsabilités j'aurais pu faire un
bouquin beaucoup plus consensuel auprès
des artistes mais il me semble que leur
réaction pendant la pandémie est
indicative de ce qu'un certain nombre
d'entre eux n'ont pas vain semble-t-il
je le dis en même temps avec beaucoup de
modestie
la lucidité politique pour comprendre
pourquoi on en est là
en d'autres termes toute la période qui
a précédé les artistes se sont exprimés
sur le terrain tout à fait légitime de
la déploration de la revendication mais
surtout de l'incompréhension dix ans
mais pourquoi est ce que les théâtres
les musées sont fermés alors que telle
ou telle institution commerciales des
grandes surfaces des transports etc sont
ouvertes c'est à dire que s'il fallait
trouver un élément de résumé de leur
position si on ne comprend pas ça paraît
totalement contradictoire et c'est pas
justifiée or il me semble ou alors
d'autres je pense en particulier aux
propos de charles berling accusant
directement le gouvernement de vouloir
quelque sorte en finir avec les acteurs
culturels et il me semble que évidemment
cette thèse de mon point de vue n'est
pas recevable
l'explication elle est beaucoup plus
simple l'explication me semble-t-il
c'est que la question culturelle n'est
plus dans l'environnement mental
intellectuel immédiat de la plupart
des décideurs politiques et c'est ce qui
explique qu'on s'a peut-il que lors du
premier confinement le président de la
république n'a même pas prononcer le mot
culture et lorsque peu de temps après ce
premier ministre confirme et le
confinement il n'a pas non plus
mentionné la culture c'est à dire que
c'est comme c'est un sujet hors champ
donne d'ailleurs pourrait retrouver les
illustrations dans l'ensemble des débats
politiques lors des campagnes
électorales et si je suis par exemple
les débats autour des présidentielles et
législatives etc
on voit bien que la culture est réduite
à une portion totalement congrue que
finalement c'est une forme de de
supplément d'âme respectable mais qui
n'est pas au coeur de la question de
l'organisation sociétale et moi je pense
exactement l inverse
c'est la question notamment de caisse
qui est essentiel qu'est ce qui n'est
pas essentiel
mais il suffit pas de pour les artistes
de te dire que c'est essentiel il faut
au contraire c'est comme l'amour il n'y
a pas d'amour bien que des preuves
d'amour
or dans bien des cas je cite quelques
les illustrations de ce que j'appelle
des fragments d'une lucidité politique
absente des artistes n'ont pas
nécessairement toujours été très lucide
sur un certain nombre d'événements est
par ailleurs accepte toute une série de
contradictions notamment dans le cadre
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler les effets
d'aubaine de l'exception culturelle
voilà en gros le la thématique de mon
propos mais on dirait que c'est le
niveau général qui a b c c'est à dire
que les politiques leur niveau a baissé
je parle notamment de leur niveau
culturel les médias aussi qui ont
remplacé la culture par le
divertissement
la conséquence de tout savez vous l'air
de dire c'est que notre rayonnement
culturel à l'étranger qui était très
grand
s'est effondré on en a eues preuve
encore avec la fameuse couverture du
time qu'on va voir
qui dit que les l'afrique food culture
française n'existe plus qu'elle est
qu'elle est morte et on se dit après on
pensa à toul et les politiques qui ont
précédé alors au général de gaulle qui
était un type très cultivé qui me mais
qui ne parlait jamais de culture y
laisser ça à andré malraux qui était un
très grand écrivain et en plus un homme
de culture et qui a laissé un grand
souvenir en tant que ministre des
affaires culturelles mais pompidou par
exemple très cultivé très intelligent un
ministre la culture très cultivé maurice
druon mais qui n'a pas laissé un grand
souvenir de deux grands ministre
mitterrand très cultivé avec jack lang
qui lui laisse un grand souvenir en tant
que ministre de la culture
et puis après c'est vrai on a
l'impression qu'ils sont désintéresse un
peu même si jacques chirac est très
cultivé lui aussi dans son genre dans
l'impression que ça les intéresse plus
tellement jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors on a l'impression que ça dépend de
quoi vous vous voyez les rôles l'origine
de ce désintérêt alors d'abord le
constat est simple et il est tout à fait
évident si vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure que à l'origine je suis prof de
droit si on se réfère à la définition
des missions du ministère de la culture
dans les textes
nous avons en 82 avec malraux un souci
d'identifier en effet un sens des
politiques culturelles autour de se
rappeler la démocratisation culturelle
c'est à dire l'accès plus grand nombre
aux plus grands des oeuvres de l'esprit
c'est très clair ensuite jack lang c'est
une autre logique mais ça ne mérite le
décret d'ailleurs symboliquement du 10
mai 81 2 définit également une autre
conception qu'on a qualifiée de
démocratie culturelle qui a débouché
ensuite il a su le débat évidemment sur
le tout culturel et qui consiste à
encourager en quelque sorte les
capacités créatrices de chaque individu
en considérant une fideua de manière
implicite que chacun d'entre nous serait
capable
de créer qui convient donc de permettre
à chacun de s'exprimer dans la
reconnaissance des pratiques amateurs
etc etc je vous et puis je vous invite à
vous parce que vous le définissez bien
le le tout culturel de jacques lang vous
dites ne pouvant rendre culturel nous ne
pouvons rendre le culturel populaire
on a rendu on a fait en sorte que le
populaire deviennent culturel en fait ce
serait salle culturelle 1 et c'est comme
ça qu'on essaye d ce que certains
considéraient autrefois comme de la
sous-culture on en a fait des grandes
cultures
c'est ça alors je crois que c'était déjà
un premier malentendu
d'ailleurs pour dire lorsque l'enseigné
moi même et vous avez compris quelle
était ma conception de la culture
mes étudiants dans les masters 2
considérer que mon propos était
réactionnaire que j'étais un
conservateur par delà ce que je crois
être fondamentalement en place
politiques parce que précisément je
considérais que tout n'était pas
équivalent à tous or ce qui a dans la
tête de beaucoup de jeunes générations
aujourd'hui c'est une modalité en
quelque sorte de ce qu'on a qualifié de
multiculturalisme dans les pays anglo
saxons c'est à dire que finalement
toutes les cultures seraient respectable
et du coup on laisse un certain nombre
de deux classes sociales de catégories
sociales dans des formes de sous culture
tout en leur décernant la belle de deux
légitimités identique
alors pour répondre plus directement à
votre question parce que je peux
observer pendant des années comme
universitaire dans notamment la
préparation de nos élites les grands
concours de l'état de l'autre fonction
publique les questions artistiques ou
culturels sont totalement absentes
c'est à dire que ne reprend pas dans le
bouquin des anecdotes qui sont assez
cruel sur l'état des lieux en quelque
sorte de la culture d'un certain nombre
de nos responsables politiques elles
sont connues elles ont été souvent
raillé mais on comprend en effet que
dans les cursus de ceux qui par exemple
près par l'ena les lectures qui sont au
programme sont des lectures qui sont
basés sur la performance pour réussir le
grand court mais qui en quelques sortes
ne met pas au premier plan c'est un
euphémisme la question des de la culture
classique de la littérature etc
et moi j'ai pu observer d'ailleurs je le
dis d'une phrase c'est assez révélateur
j'ai créé par exemple à la fac un master
2 de management culturel et promos après
promo jean landry conne que la plupart
des étudiants qui avaient été retenus
alors même que par définition il avait
manifesté un appétit très très fort pour
la culture qu'ils avaient été retenus au
terme d'un processus très sélectif
l'immense majorité d'entre ces tireurs
les deux tiers plus de la moitié n'avait
jamais mis bac + 5
jamais mis les pieds ni dans un musée ni
dans un théâtre ne parlons même pas
d'autres pratiques culturelles plus
distinctive
donc c'est un vrai problème ça mérite
bien une
il ya eu un avant et un déficit complet
alors que paradoxalement pendant très
longtemps ce qu'on appelait peu
approximativement les beaux-arts est
tout simplement une direction du
ministère de l'instruction publique dans
ça signifie que c'était la matrice de
l'instruction publique de l'enseignement
qui était en quelque sorte le géniteur
des questions culturelles et puis avec
le temps les deux questions étaient
totalement séparées alors ça je ne dis
pas dans mon petit bouquin parce que
c'est plus de l'ordre du jour mais moi
qui suis très admiratif de l'oeuvre de
malraux en maintenant la période de
marwa une responsabilité c'est à dire
que malheureux penser que dans le
rapport artistique
si tu t'en rapport d'amour c'est à dire
on aime la culture on aime la création
artistique mais ça ne s'enseigne pas et
donc il ya une vraie rupture à son malin
c'est à dire l'idée selon laquelle le
rapport à l'oeuvre goûts culturels était
un rapport purement charismatique
individuelles qui était totalement en
quelque sorte extérieur à toute logique
didactiques pédagogiques etc
alors évidemment ça paraît paradoxal
puisque en même temps moi je salue la
proche de marveaux qui de mon point de
vue a été de loin le plus grand ministre
de la culture les deux seuls qui ont
vraiment laissé une trace en effet sont
les deux noms que nous avons évoqués est
ce qu'ils ont en commun de sable et il
sait que l'un et l'autre très grande
proximité avec le politique au sens le
plus magistral dans notre vème
république
par définition jupitérienne depuis
cinquante-huit de gaulle choisit malraux
commises des affaires culturelles en le
définissant comme mon ami génial
quels sont les autres amis géniaux de
président de la république on a eu au
poste de ministre de la culture
si on m'a parlé la période actuelle en
tout cas
et les langues chacun sait bien qu'il
avait depuis fort longtemps une
proximité très forte avec me tourner
pardon non adhérents serge regourd mais
au fond on comprend bien et dans votre
petit livre vous le mettez bien
qu'aujourd'hui pour la plupart des de
nos dirigeants politiques la culture n'a
plus qu'un poids économique
on compte on compte on est incapable de
trier entre ce qui est intéressant ce
n'est pas intéressant aux comptes est
l'exemple pour moi elle était très bien
donner en 2017
tr knight bredin à l'époque à la tête du
chêne c'est je crois avait félicité
parce que 209 millions de spectateurs
avaient été aussi les mains au cours de
l'année 2017 et elle disait c'est
extraordinaire c'est comme en 1968
donc avant que les cinémas se vide
sauf que en 1968 les films qu'on avait
vu que les gens allaient voir en masse à
part de funès et bourvil
enfin qu'ils avaient leur charme
c'étaient les affiches qu'on va voir
derrière moi c'était 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace de kubrick
c'était le bal des vampires de romane
polonsky c'était le bon la brute et le
truand de sergio leone
c'était bonnie and clyde d'arthur penn
tous ces films là faisait des millions
d'entrées en 1968 en france où le
lauréat de mike nichols ou la planète
des singes des films que aujourd'hui
encore cinquante ans après on continue
tous de regarder si vous regardez en
2017 ou il ya eu 209 millions de gens
qui sont elles aussi les mailles sont
allés voir quoi c'est la liste un peu
triste qu'on a à côté sont allés voir
star wars huit fast furious 8
les gardiens de la galaxie deux pirates
des caraïbes 5 jumanji deux spider man
16les comédie de dany boon et de
philippe lachaux on remplaçait bourvil
et de funès je suis pas sûr qu'on les
regarde encore dans 50 ans voilà c'est à
dire qu'à un moment il ya toujours
autant de gens dans les cinémas il ya
toujours autant de films qui sont
produits mais c'est plus du tout le même
niveau
ben je crois que votre constat à partir
du prisme de cinéma est encore plus
implacable que le mieux c'est à dire que
ne peut évidemment que quelques adhérer
qu'acquiescer mais je crois que c'est
effectivement un bon prisme pour
remettre en cause deux logiques purement
quantitative de la caricature absolue
alors bost peu méchant et ça ça me vaut
quelques problèmes avec les amis
politiques entre guillemets mais même à
ma scène introductive et
emprunter un documentaire de mon avis
documentariste violent où on montre le
président de la république et le premier
ministre accueillir la nouvelle ministre
de la culture en l'occurrence fleur
pellerin qui leur demande ce qu'elle
doit faire et la manière dont on lui
répond montre que quiconque aucun axe
politique qui en gros il faut avoir des
idées qui suffisent à les voir jack lang
et son épouse monique et qui leur
donneront des idées et ensuite ce qu'ils
prévoient c'est exactement ce que vous
dites c'est à dire des logiques de pure
quantités qui vont conduire la susnommée
à coire avec le concours d'un prix nobel
d'économie que je connais un petit peu a
essayé de tenter de définir une
politique culturelle à partir des
algorithmes ce qui doit pas de vue le
contraire absolu d'une politique
culturelle puisque proposé est ce que
les gens connaissent déjà
c'est totalement opposées alors pas
tomber dans la cuistrerie mais des plus
belles citations de définition de la
culture que je reprends est dûe aux
poètes qui était par ailleurs diplomate
saint john perse qui définissait la
culture comme le leak le luxe de l'ina
coutume ans c'est à dire que ça au site
un problème fondamental dans la mesure
où lorsque les sur le terrain de la
qualité entre guillemets que vous
évoquiez la question fondamentale dans
le domaine artistique de la création de
simples et il ça renvoie la question de
guinée dit que de saint john perse aux
normes d'une accoutumance
or aujourd'hui toutes les politiques
culturelles sont menées à partir de
dispositifs techniques de normes de
formats de quantité etc qui décide si
oui ou non on peut financier l'activité
alors j'entends bien que c'est de
l'argent public qu'on ne peut pas
utiliser l'argent public de manière
arbitraire mais soumettre le encore une
fois la logique de la création
c'est-à-dire de l'inédit
à partir de critères et qui n'ont de
sens que par rapport à ce qui a déjà été
fait c'est déjà une contradiction dans
les termes qui requiert de la part des
décideurs politiques vraiment une très
grande marge de l'appétence pour la
question artistique et la question
culturelle et donc on est effectivement
là dans une forme de weeds d'impasse
d'autant ce sort uniquement avec des
données l'encore qualitative parce que
dans la dernière période veut pas
accabler la ministre actuelle mais qui
est très fier que le budget de la
culture pour 1921 pour 2021
pardonnez-moi lotus va être augmenté de
2,4 2,8 pour cent mais ça n'a aucun sens
dans le cadre de vivre aujourd'hui le
plan de relance pour la culture et c'est
très bien
prévoit 2 millions d'euros pour la
culture très bien sauf que ce même
gouvernement nous dit que pour 2020 pour
2020 le déficit dans ce domaine et 2,22
milliards dont 2 milliards pour
compenser 22 lien à plus et devient soir
le plan de relance et sur deux ans mais
il fallait surtout pas essayer de tenir
un discours sur le terrain de la
quantité puisque la quantité
salah de sens des moyens de repos de vue
que lorsqu'on l'a bien déterminé des
finalités des objectifs or on est en
permanence sur des questions de chiffres
de nombres alors que la question de mon
point de vue n'est pas là c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs je ne parle pas du tout de la
question des moyennes qui est certes une
question importante mais avant les
moyens comme d'ailleurs et hi matic mans
lundi que le terme des moyens dans deux
sens que par rapport à des finalités par
rapport à des objectifs
or aujourd'hui
ce serait peu dire que nous sommes en
panne d'où la définition de ces
objectifs d'où le titre sos culture le
titre de votre livre qui vient juste de
paraître aux éditions indigène ont fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
theresa ira de vous appeler thérèse
parce que c'est sous votre prénom que
l'on vous connais vous être la chanteuse
du groupe la vague et vous sortez en
solo chinoise avec un point
d'interrogation voici un extrait du clip
il est tout neuf on le regarde shenley
massage poli soumise au lieu qu'on
m'écoute unis chinese pagny sentir
cucchi le 6 legault mi-2010 ma vie
chantôme conneries manga par tabac
jackie chan constitue le tabac 6 sourire
matheu mafieux mini physique vers ce qui
touche je me lavais remis je cois
n'échappe aux attentes
[Musique]
apprenez tout petit en vidéo
mais
mais thérèse dans qu'elle en veut tu le
dises niort konichiwa zarate katzav a
dit qu'à banias parce que ce même combat
we go quel rapport avec marie cottin
seul compte répond pas c'est que ton
d'elle pourquoi tu abordes tu veux
monter
voilà mon toit à dire que j'adore je
bois du château à temps
à
[Musique]
taponier
et peut-être même à gagner ce bras et
gros chien comme toi chez cash et mâcher
de mon menu métro à les balkany jean
près du phare aussi la jam
fais danser soja cackle de connard
du kif le karaoké hsh émis aux cadets
avoue l'as étaples ok ramat une dernière
fois mon faciale tonia thérèse c'est le
coronavirus c'est le racisme anti
chinois que qui en a découlé surtout au
début qui vous a donné envie de décrire
cette chanson et de l'enregistrer et
d'en faire un clip ça a accéléré sa sa a
confirmé ma remontée effectivement de
sortir cette chaîne sont en fait pour
tout vous avouer là j'ai commencé à
écrire la chanson en anglais et en
chinois il ya déjà deux ans de ça et je
l'avais un petit peu laissé de côté
parce que j'étais dans le groupe la
vague qui d'ailleurs s'est arrêtée
depuis et est en fait pendant le premier
confinement et même juste avant j'ai été
pas mal sollicité par des médias pour
justement prendre la parole au sujet de
la montée de la sinophobie et plus
généralement de du racisme anti
asiatique en france et en occident et
donc on a pendant le premier confinement
géré abattu un petit peu l'écart et je
suis d'accord avec ce que disait serge
tout à l'heure je trouve qu'il ya aussi
une sorte d'abandon d'une politique
culturelle est aussi incertaine abandon
de la part de des artistes sur voilà la
scène j'ai envie de dire politique ou
moins engagés vis-à-vis de la société et
moi je me suis posé pas une question à
cette époque là il ya un an j'ai décidé
de voilà de faire autre chose que ce que
j'appelle aujourd'hui de la
entertainment du divertissement et de me
mettre voilà de m'impliquer plus dans le
combat sociétaux et on en a découlé de
cette chanson qui que j'ai voulu
traduire de l'anglais au français
puisque j'habite en france et que je
voulais vraiment que le message passe du
coup voilà c'est ce qui est un petit peu
motivé l'écriture et puis et puis la
sortie de cette chanson et que ce plu
mais du racisme on sait qui en a tous on
sait qui est du racisme anti noir qui
est du racisme anti arabe est ce qu'il
ya vraiment du racisme anti asiatique
autrement que celui qu'on a pu voir se
manifester au début du camp des virus ou
effectivement envoyé dans le métro des
gens s'éloignent et quand il voyait des
personnes soient chinois soit qu'il
n'était pas du tout qu'ils étaient comme
vous entièrement française mais qui
rappelait qu'il y avait un virus qui se
baladait quelque part voilà le racisme
anti chinois vous l'avez subi vous je
les subis je les subis en fait le
racisme anti asiatique et c'est quelque
chose d'assez complexe comme tous les
racismes de toute façon parce que il a
muté il a muté ces dernières années la
dernière année 2020 a été effectivement
la manifestation de d'actes au départ il
y avait des personnes qui s'éloignait
des personnes qui avaient l'air
asiatique t comme on dit maintenant dans
le jargon un habitant voilà qui avait
l'air de personnes asiatiques t et moi
quelque part j'ai compris ce principe de
précaution même s'il n'était pas
agréable
en revanche ce que je dis souvent c'est
que ya un moment où on a le choix
on a le choix de d'agir de telle ou de
telle façon et j'ai fait une sorte de
parallélisme avec la le lendemain des
attentats
au lendemain des attentats on avait le
choix effectivement de décider
d'amalgamé toutes les personnes arabe ou
qui avait l'air arabe avec des
terroristes ou non est en fait ce que je
voulais dire c'est que à un moment donné
on a le choix de ne pas amalgamer
justement toutes les personnes de sa
sieste asiatique avec pékin et le
coronavirus mais ces tendances par point
de départ doit d'intervenir mais il ya
des clichés sur toutes les communautés
on sait bien quelles qu'elles soient sur
tous les pays on a tous hâte est pleine
de clichés plutôt favorable ou plutôt
défavorable que ce soit l'italienne
lover ou le français avec son béret sa
baguette de pain on sait tous que c'est
pas vrai mais on sait aussi que partout
on voit les gens y pensent
en quoi c'est grave il y en a un certain
nombre que vous énumérez
dans votre chanson on me dit c'est pas
grave telle importance
effectivement il ya plein de gens qui se
disent que c'est pas grave le souci
c'est que il ya un moment où il faut
distinguer les moqueries on peut avoir
dans la cour d'école dans la rue au
boulot et c'est dans la vie quotidienne
avec des personnes qui se font
littéralement tabassé pour rien dans la
rue aujourd'hui en 2020 je crois que il
ya énormément de personnes qui n'ont pas
porté plainte mais on a recensé plus de
40 personnes qui se sont fait agresser
physiquement et dont donc dont le cas le
plus grave on semble que c'etait 21
jours d'itt était donc lite et et pour
ceux qui ne savent pas c'est
l'incapacité temporaire tout ça de
pouvoir travailler donc la personne
n'est toujours pas et toujours à fatal à
retourner au travail
et voilà on en est là aujourd'hui ou
parce qu'on est de faciès asiatiques
on se retrouve à être victime de
lynchage
on se fait tabasser dans la rue des
gamines se font cracher dessus à l'école
taper à l'école et c'est simplement
parce qu'elle on s'assied synthétique
moi je me suis retrouvé en tant que
française à devoir me justifier des
politiques de pékin au sujet des
ouigours c'est quelque part j'ai envie
de dire mais là on en est un point où
tout est mélangé
et en fait quelque part les médias et
puis les politiques de ces je dirais 15
dernières années n'ont absolument pas
aidé la puissance de la chine est en
train de faire peur aux pays occidentaux
de façon totalement légitime et en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la peur
géopolitique des grandes puissances de
nos dirigeants etc
et petit à petit redescendu dans la pop
il est dans la population à travers les
médias et d'autres choses quand un trump
évidemment appel pendant un an le cours
aux navires russes le virus chinois il
est peu étonnant finalement que les gens
finissent par faire des amalgames et
amalgamer par exemple persuy abonnés
de vous interrompre herminio il y avait
eu 1 1 au moment où kiev adams et gad
elmaleh avait fait un sketch sur les
chinois il y avait une toute petite
partie mais une petite partie de la la
communauté asiatique en france qui
avaient protesté vraiment pas beaucoup
hein
mais est ce que vous étiez seriati vous
même agressé à ce moment là alors je me
souviens qu effectivement anthony
chesneau qui est donc qui travaille chez
clic
et puis luiz chelsea une une djette et
grâce lee avait effectivement réagi sur
les réseaux sociaux
et moi je m'étais sentie concernée par
par par ce sketch où l'humour quelque
part c'est quelque chose qui est
subjectif est propre à chacun je pense
qu'on peut rire de cloud je fais partie
ces personnes là et pas avec n'importe
qui un humoriste qui ne nous fait pas
rire on n'est pas obligé d'aller y
regarder on n'est pas obligé de de
partager ses sketches etc etc
en revanche lorsque dans ses sketches et
véhiculer la son véhicule et des clichés
qui peuvent être dangereux et qui
peuvent pas porter préjudice aux
communautés là ça devient problématique
et c'est justement ce qui s'est passé il
est sous-entendu des asiatiques qui aime
l'argent etc etc ont eu pour conséquence
dans la société des agressions en
cascade de d'énormément de personnes
d'origine asiatique en france bien un
rite de un rite de passage à vitry sur
seine qui s'appelle se faire un chinois
et c'est donc c'est donc dépouillés en
fait un asiatique et puis lui casser la
gueule
et le problème c'est que quand les
chaînes de grande audience permettent ce
genre de permettre à ces humoristes et à
ce genre de sketches de dire absolument
tout ce qu'ils veulent ça banalise d'une
part les clichés ça banalise humour
qu'on peu comment dire
la façon dont on peut et dont on est
autorisée en fait à s'adresser aux
populations asiatiques de france
et en plus ça devient dangereux parce
qu'en plus ils sont faits signifie
finissent par se faire agresser pour
rien et à en perdre la vie comme comme
c'est arrivé avec charline en 2016
la chanson s'appelle chinoise s'est donc
une carrière solo donc vous débutez
maintenant thérèse jeu puisque la drague
n'existe plus victime du camp des virus
j'imagine et du confinement
on va maintenant s'intéresser dans la
musique classique c'est autre chose
[Musique]
l'eia petrova vous êtes violoniste vous
êtes bulgare vous avez commencé à jouer
en soliste dès l'âge de 6 ans vous avez
remporté en 2016 le premier prix du
concours international de violon carl
nielsen et vous sortez un nouvel album
dont voici un extrait du teaser vous
écoute immédiatement
[Musique]
oh
il ya petrova vous regardent leurs
jouets là je me disais qu'au fond le
violon était la musique classique ce que
la guitare électrique est au rock and
roll et à et le saxophone au jazz mais
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que le violon
est à ce point
l'instrument de ce qu'on appelle la
musique classique qui recouvre toute
sorte de musique à travers les siècles
mais ce qui pour nous est tout
simplement la musique classique mais
toutes ces musiques à travers les
siècles ont en commun le viol ou parce
que le violon moi et comme est très
proche de l'ovaire en fait c'est très
proche de la voix humaine contrairement
au piano par exemple on dit souvent que
le violoncelle ressemble beaucoup à
l'erreur est humaine mais moi je trouve
ça aussi il est beaucoup plus grand et
beaucoup plus grave
alors que le violon on tient aussi très
proche de notre corps presque comme un
bébé et comme quelque chose qu'on aime
très fort et en tout cas c'est le cas
pour moi et je pense que moi entrer en
jeu quand j'écoute souvent le violon et
notamment le concerto de beethoven
mozart qu'on va parler je pense de
l'opéra et les haricots nu des opéras de
mozart 2 d'autres groupes visiteurs de
berra ou vraiment le voix féminine
je pense que les violons sillet rappelle
beaucoup les voix féminines mais son
prince à l'avant le principal mais je
pense à la petite fille que vous étiez à
6 ans quand vous commencez à devenir
soliste jeudi cette petite fille de six
ans font en ayant choisi le violon elle
ne pourra jouer que de la musique
classique parce que ni le jazz ni
l'europe n'ont besoin du violon ce sera
la musique classique ou alors accompagné
des chanteurs français d'un certain âge
en fait il ya comme je mets deux
violonistes qui commence maintenant de
faire entrer du jazz un peu d'autres
styles quand j'étais teenagers j'aimais
beaucoup je jouais dans une
gros buzz de rock on peut dire aux
jeunes pros visé au violon mais c'est
vrai que ma passion dès que les l'âge de
4 4,5 ans je voulais parler musique
classique en fait j'étais je le sentais
très fort moment d'ailleurs il ya même
mes parents qui étaient pas très
positive l'idée est ce que ma maman elle
est pianiste et l'on bulgarie à l'époque
aujourd'hui toujours c'est pas facile
pour les gens qui font une musique
classique
du coup elle me déconseillait fortement
de faire de la musique classique
il pensait que c'est une très mauvaise
idée et j'ai même appris le violon en
tout cas dans le premier six mois en
sept manches en cachette avec mon oncle
j'avais convaincre que je le disais s'il
te plaît à prendre moi parce que ma
maman il va jamais le faire qu'ils vont
finalement tout le monde a accepté quand
ils m'ont vu avec le petit violon et ils
ont vraiment compris que c'est un choix
et que c'est pas juste une petite idée
qui m'est passé par la tête sont là mais
en effet je pense que je pense que le
violon de plus en plus quand ce d'être
associé aussi d'autres gens non mais
quand la vous en venez d'enregistrer un
album donc pour violon bien entendu
concerto pour violon ce sont des
concertos pour violon de mozart et
beethoven qui sont contemporains l'un de
l'autre mais je me souviens dans votre
album précédent vous aviez enregistré du
benjamin britten est dû
et du cml d'ardeur et qui eux sont des
compositeurs du 20e siècle
est ce qu'il ya une différence dans
l'écriture entre l'écriture ancienne on
va dire de btv de mazars et celle de
britten et barber plus récente plus
moderne tout à fait d'ailleurs commune
entre les arts comme on regarde par
exemple les tableaux de xviiie siècle
ils sont très différents des tableaux de
20e et aujourd'hui encore quand je pense
que c'est exactement dans la musique
classique les compositeurs n'étaient ils
sont toujours très influencé par le par
le temps par ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
on peut prendre par exemple les ans que
de better même si les sujets qui
l'occupé pendant ce comme liberté je
pense que c'était c'était vraiment un
grand humaniste
quand même il était créé crêperie pas
l'air occupé je pensais et pour lui
c'était important
la révolution française elle est à
l'époque il ya une histoire très connue
parce qu'il était vraiment un grand
admirateur de napoléon et au
développement début et il avait même des
10 clefs dédiés ça la symphonie héroïque
à un apollon et au moment qu'il a
entendu qu'en fait finalement nos pôles
on est revenu au roi à part voir mais
bon voilà
du coup il se dit oh non il était
tellement déçu et déchiré sa partition
et il a dit que ça sera la symphonie
héroïque à l'infini pour le peuple et
pas pour encore un qui se prend pour
avoir voilà je pense que je pense que
l'album voilà c'est ça qui sait ce qui
l'intéressé et va aujourd'hui les sujets
sont différents et en effet la musique
de britney de voir que j'avais
enregistrée dans mon précédent album
album est beaucoup et beaucoup plus
romantique dans un sens moderne je vais
te dire qu'à celle de better gottex et
moser vais aussi même si on parle
beaucoup de beaucoup d'amour
je pense pensant occupe surtout des
sujets
un peu plus spirituel de sujets de
liberté aussi dans le camp certes de
better je trouve que c'est normal et
s'envole de symbole de l'espoir parce
que dans le premier mouvement il ya
vraiment deux motifs qui sont en guerre
permanente en permanence tout le temps
pendant 20 minutes on s'est moqué de
lamballe ça commence comme ça vraiment
avec quatre notes qui nous rappelle une
motif de guerre et l'autre motif c'est
vraiment de chansons très naïve on a
l'impression que c'est des petits
enfants qui chantent et ces deux motifs
il se bat tout le temps finalement c'est
le sait c'est le beau c'est l'espoir est
celle des voix des enfants qui gagne on
va on va écouter un autre extrait
[Musique]
oh
e
et
non
[Musique]
il ya petrova dans cet album vous êtes
accompagné d'un grand orchestre cannelle
différence pour une soliste tels que
vous d'être accompagné par un orchestre
symphonique ou par ou de faire de la
musique de chambre d'être accompagné
juste d'un piano par exemple comme
c'était le cas dans l'album précédent
mais je crois que j'aime beaucoup la
musique de chambre aussi est-ce que vous
jouer différemment
en fait dans l'idéal ça devrait être la
même chose parce que même quand on est
con vous panier parra sont musiciens sur
scène
l'idée c'est quand même de faire de la
musique de chambre avec c'est vraiment
d'avoir une partage qui vient des deux
côtés
évidemment que l'énergie qu'on ressent
sur scène comme son personnel non qui
joue avec est forcément différente qu'en
seulement avec une ou deux trois
personnes et pense que c'est une des
choses qui me manque le plus aujourd'hui
cette sensation sur scène qu'on a
vraiment son personnes en gaussin contre
60 ça dépend des oeuvres évident mais
évidemment mais un grand grand orchestre
symphonique se tendent aux façons de soi
qu'on a vraiment l'impression de créer
quelque chose ensemble
la force et l'énergie est juste
incroyable
et d'ailleurs c'est une expérience qui
est très partagée aussi avec le public
c'est malheureusement quelque chose qu
on a presque oublié aujourd'hui mais le
public participe aussi à 100% dans ces
moments là et je pense que quand tous
les éléments sont là où ils doivent être
vraiment on est ouverts
intentionnellement à cette expérience
ça devient inoubliable
cette dernière question et livia
pétrolier petrobas ont fait la
différence entre le violon classique
comme vous le violon tzigane qu'on a
tendance à trouver le spontané plus
improvisées plus libre au fond
qu'est ce que vous faites vous comme
différence avec le violon tzigane
mais en fait moi je dors moi j'adore
cette musique j'adore improvisé et la
vérité malheureusement ce que enfin
malheureusement c'est malheureusement
pour nous mettre dans un sens parce que
tous quand je vous ai déjà écrit mais
d'autres d'autres côté cédé oeuvre
absolument génial better blues r c'était
les plus grands génies en fait dans la
musique dans tous les gens que je trouve
et du coup c'est sûr que nous on écrit
quelque chose qui était déjà 11 août
pardon quelque chose qui était déjà
écrit et joué des centaines milliers de
voix alors qu'elle a vue du long tigane
comme vous l'appelez c'est
l'improvisation à 100%
du coup il ya beaucoup de liberté mais
on a un petit moment dans le concerto
qui s'appelle cadence et la cadence est
exactement ça c'est moment dans lequel
on a le choix on a aussi la liberté
d'improviser de jouer quelque chose qui
qu'on veut et qui est pas l écrit et on
peut prendre cette liberté et prend
beaucoup de plaisir d'improviser un peu
ce nouvel album donc c'est mozart et
beethoven le précédent il y avait des
tofs barber et britten
qu'est-ce qui préside à vos choix
d'enregistrement c'est toujours très
différents je pense que c'est beaucoup
lié à comment je me sens sur le moment
par exemple bétail et britten et barbare
la bande avant du coup c'était très
influencé par l'époque par le moment
dans lequel je passais deux
de ma vie je pense que c'est un moment
difficile et c'était aussi exactement
pareil pour les compositeurs le moment
qu'ils ont écrit cette musique là cette
fois ci c'était vraiment un concerto de
beethoven
parce qu'au début de koh vide qui était
d'ailleurs en notre époque pas si facile
mais finalement ça ne pouvait pas le
savoir en avance mais du coup je me suis
dit que j'ai envie de créer quelque
chose de ce qu'il disait serge total ans
a marqué un peu penser à ça parce que
forcément je n'avais pas envie juste
d'attendre que ça se termine et le
concert todo better comme je l ai déjà
dit j'espère moi c'est le symbole de
l'espoir
du coup j'avais besoin de cet espoir je
pense qu'aussi le public on a tous
besoin d'espoir je pense que le music
nous donne beaucoup ça et c'était
sûrement une des raisons pourquoi je me
suis occupé avec vous beaucoup avec
better aussi j'écris un festival à la
salle cortot qui était qui s'appelle la
musique reste parisienne mais les
premières éditions qui est en mai
dernier était consacré à beethoven 100%
en plus c'était son 250e anniversaire
n'est pas parce que c'était sa façon
elle vient du coup je me suis compliqué
nous plonger plonger dans sa musique
dans sa vie et ça m'a beaucoup aidé et
en détail
merci beaucoup l'iab et trouva merci à
tous les trois merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
je